. Okay. It's been a couple of weeks since
we've had any hatriot male on the program.
Now, there's been no shortage of me receiving
it. We've just had so many stories to cover.
I do want to get some hatriot mail in front
of you today. Just a quick reminder about
what hatriot mail is.
Why don't you take some hydroxyl chloroquine
for that Trump derangement syndrome eyed man
written by patriots who hate David Pakman
because of America and because freedom.
OK, let's get right into it. This is so you
know, we've seen a lot of disregard, Ford,
disregard for the Constitution and the First
Amendment and the rule of law lately from
people who claim to be constitutional conservatives.
That's the context through which we should
consider today's hatriot mail.
See what you fail to realize David Pakman
is that your talk pisses off a lot of patriotic
Americans. Your talk is treason and you should
be tried and executed. And it's punks like
you who will get the coming civil war started.
Guess what happens then, you traitor. You
are held accountable for your treasonous words.
Yeah. So if there is going to be a civil war,
it will be because the people who would still
be on the pro slavery confederacy today are
going to take up guns and try to start a civil
war. The civil war is not going to be started
by people who want health care for everybody.
Right. The civil war is not going to be started
by it, by those who believe that we should
have proper oversight and reform of police
departments. That's civil war is going to
be from people who still think that the Confederacy
was the right side of the actual civil war.
And it seems it's not just it's not just Trump
throwing around the word treason, as he did
yesterday about Barack Obama. It's also hatriot
that are doing it. Remember that you can fight
hatriot TISM by using the coupon code Hatriot
40. We have this code hatriot 40. It chops
40 percent off of the cost of a membership
on my Web site and the hatriot cry every time
it's used. It's spelled h h t r i o t for
zero.